I'm wearing pleather shorts to clearly
indicates that this video is a cooking
video Halloween is fast approaching and
the more I think about Halloween the
more I think is this a holiday that was
invented by a tweeker who got a
make-a-wish I want to dress up in a
costume and go around my neighborhood
and everyone has to give me candy when I
knock on their door in honor of
Halloween I got this it sticks with real
life pumpkins on it and then some other
gross mulched festive one of the most
stereotypical Halloween treats is candy
corn everyone buys it no one actually
enjoys it I've never looked at a safety
cone before I've been like I want that
in my mouth but as a plan word so that
today I'm making candy corn I'm making
cornbread muffins cupcake hybrids with
candy inside she can't go on welcome to
white-trash Pinterest and then I'm going
to try and decorate them real cute but
you know what they say
ambition sometimes more important than
in the execution okay let's make our
corn bread mix gluten-free what is
gluten and why are we all of a sudden
not supposed to do it to ourselves one
box one cup water 1/2 cup oil 1 large
egg oh I need things to measure cooking
requires so many props cooking is like
the carrot top of the domestic industry
great oven to 350 degrees I already did
that because I'm super smart greased pan
lightly with nonstick cooking spray
then come by water around egg in a
medium sized bowl and whisk until smooth
you look real medium you're welcome
water was invented by a super dehydrated
fish he was from Sweden some people
refer to him as a Steve that was his
name waters in
cool one large egg you could be bigger
and whisk until smooth there's a whisk
no whisk no reward gotta use a fork add
cornbread and continue whisking until
combined we get it whisking is back Oh
opening bags with substances that could
go everywhere it's just as terrifying as
blowing up a balloon which is also how I
realized that I've become an adult is
that I am fearful of these things ah
okay mix what do you moonlight as a fog
machine now we're going to put you into
the muffin man Oh cute look really
grainy I like my pattern like I like my
pornography Riu grainy there's something
bad and left over because Oh with the
batter left over you could just make
yourself like a really cute centerpiece
yeah y-necklace it's up to you now it's
time for the candy I got some Twix
unwrapped bites doesn't that sounds so
appetizing when they put unwrapped in
the title I like my tricks like I like
my men unwrapped it's getting always
wear protection so cute now these are
going to go in the middle of each one
then I also got some actual candy corn
to try in here I have low expectations
for you guys this feels very
cannibalistic get in there dudes now is
your opportunity to become something
better than you actually are going into
the others help you cook for 20 to 25
minutes
was that okay to eat so while you have
to wait twenty twenty-five minutes for
your candy corn it cook here it's like
it really didn't want me to have a
conversation with you some things you
can do while you're waiting on I don't
know listen to an audio book maybe at
audible.com made me they have 150,000
audible books to choose from also known
as audio books to choose from pornos
maybe
you go to auto micro-massage grace you
get your first download for free
maybe I'm currently listening to lena
Dunham's new book and no one knows but
like made me try on your lap calm slash
grace but again who knows Oh God how's
my indication that time is past you're
all still the same color you were but
you're just a little more bloated my
patience has run out and they look like
they're sort of done and that's really a
good sign in cooking right oh you guys
are cute and the candy corn Hans look
gross did you guys get really bothered
when I said I had low expectations also
the really hot you can't put icing on
when it's hot it's just gonna melt and I
have to wait time the cool down god
damnit cooking takes too long okay candy
corns are cool both on a social level
and the temperature level so now it's
time to decorate I got cake icing but
you can get whatever you want because
it's America unless it's the country you
live in which is not America cool down
for you being unique here's a montage of
me and decorating yeah great my
decorating is done it was a great time
just started out by saying boo and then
I put a bee in an S at the end of it
this one was going to be that old man
emoji that's my favorite emoji on the
emoji keyboard but they're just turned
in to UM some sort of happy ghost
wearing headphones and then the last one
was going to be a jack-o'-lantern but
then just turned into what will probably
make an appearance in my nightmares
tonight oh I have a cavity definitely
and very good though disa brother poster
flavors you guys thanks for watching
make your own and show me on instagram
with the hashtag why am I doing this
I don't know yeah look I got my
halloween costume guess who I am
someone that just slept ate in the
middle of the night don't forget to
subscribe if you enjoyed any of this and
like the video if you like that sort of
thing and then also go to Grace's guide
book comment pre-order my book there are
more fun recipes in the book even more
fun than this you say so if I do say I
should dabble in the blind or more often